that him he's really in touch with the
lives of ordinary people he cares very
much about his constituency work and
he's got a way of approaching politics
that is very practical and understands
the the things that need to be done to
improve people's lives he very much
focuses on people so I really believe
that is a but why would something like
for example that so-called bedroom tax
fit into that you know taking a spare
bedroom away from disabled people or
well I don't know exactly the detailing
is well I wasn't I wasn't and haven't
been around the last couple of years so
no but I mean they're going in your book
you talk about you know incentives using
the benefit system making work pay
minimum wages and that it seemed to be
all part of it but it's also seem to be
a lot of people as having quite in human
consequences but what I'm arguing in the
book is actually that that in many ways
the welfare system which is the legacy
over many many decades of different
policies by different governments has
become too bureaucratic it's too big and
is to remove from people and so what I'm
arguing if in the book about how we
tackle poverty and inequality and the
things that the welfare system is
supposed to deal with is to use a much
more human approach where you work with
individual people and their families to
try and solve some of those very deep
problems that prevent them from doing
the things we want to see like getting a
job and climbing the ladder of
opportunity right that I mean it does
just seemed to me that there's a danger
that you know you talk about new
technologies and data and how that can
make a more sensitive system it can also
make a more brutal system and that's a
dangerous it can if it's in the wrong
hands and in the wrong system and that's
why I think for me a real priority of
the kind of changes that we need is to
actually break up these big
old-fashioned systems and make things
much smaller and more localized so that
people can deal with each other in a
human way and I think that really does
apply to welfare probably more than many
many of the other public side and does
that mean that you also have to break up
the you know the Google's or the apples
you have to apply antitrust principles
to them because otherwise they become
too common oh definitely I think
antitrust is a huge part of this
argument because just as government has
got too big and bureaucratized the same
has happened in business but the real
point is not whether a company is big or
even whether it whether it and faces
enough competition it's about the
opportunity for other companies to
challenge it for new players to get into
the market and offer services and
products that are better and give people
a better deal and too many of the
companies that dominate sectors like
supermarkets and the utilities and the
banks don't really face any challenge at
all and in fact they use their insider
status to keep the competitors out now
as you freely admit you a very
well-connected person now you've known
here we measure a long time but we've
also you know you've known senior
politicians and you know you know you
accept that the people get into power
tend to come from the same backgrounds
you're against that how do you change it
I think a really big part of that is
actually showing people that politics
can be for them and encouraging people
to run for office who may think the
whole thing is is a terrible thing that
I want to get involved in politicians
speak this weird language and and do my
theory is taking say or you kept
supporter you might think it's all gonna
waste of time here we get three million
votes and we get one MP well I think
that um there's lots of arguments about
about the way that the the system works
but it's not just about Parliament
remember you can make change happen and
on the local level we're going to be
seeing I hope more directly elected
mayors that's another opportunity for
people to get involved there's loads of
ways that people can make a difference
and I think it's really important that
they see politics as something that is
for them not just for some insider elite
group and so I really want people to run
for office